upon arriving at falgrim as the
foundling we sent something nearby
something laying against a rock and
slumped over with this pulsating energy
surrounding it almost like it's saying
come closer
this is our first encounter with a shell
the shells are the remains of defeated
warriors that the foundling can interact
with
upon interacting with them the fouling
awakens the power within the shells it
can move freely inside the shell itself
using glimpses in tar the family can
also not only enhance the ability with
the shell
but also learn more about who they
awakened and that second part is what i
want to talk about today
one thing to keep in mind though is that
you will notice a trend with these
characters in particular how much of
them i describe as theory
not enough info is given to us to make
an indisputable timeline but it's enough
to work out something so keep this in
mind and i encourage you to make your
own theories as well
sister ganesa pretty much explains this
to us in the game as she tells us to
bring back more shells for us to awaken
and see
glimpses into what makes them human so
we're only seeing glimpses of their life
not full storylines in the swampy
terrain slumped over near a rock in some
grass is haros the vassal
once we awaken haros and discover his
name for the first time we get a
starting point into his story
which says quote the brigands pointed us
towards the temple
shunned by the devout their allegiances
lie with those who offer tar and spirits
they entertain themselves with drunken
antics and violent cruelties they know
better than to attack us but they follow
this at a distance hoping for scraps
already it's clear that horos is with a
group of people who are not brigands
themselves it's never told who the
members are or what the group is called
but
we'll just call them knights to make it
easier while haross and his fellow
knights were walking together they came
across the group of brigands
harold holds himself to a very high
standard and doesn't meddle with these
low lifes but he needed information so
he offered these two brigands a bag of
tar
and that is what they accept as adequate
payment harris immediately sent
betrayal among them however and knocked
one down while the other told him the
info he needed to know once he gathered
the information he needed he was on his
way
the brigands were still alive and knew
not to attack kharos and his men head on
but to stay in the back and away for the
opportune time to strike
and they did haross managed to kill them
but he was wounded
so he stumbled into a cave to rest and
hide in case more came
seeing as going into a cavern was his
first thought it's good to assume that
this wound isn't something he could walk
off
if he was caught out in the open with
that wound once more he'd most likely be
dead
while in the cave he met a priest that
priest said that he couldn't help him
with his wounds
horus had suffered but he did promise
that he could make haros be reborn
within the shadow of the revered the
biggest question now is
why was he going to the temple in the
first place clearly there is a motive
and from the other two audio logs we can
kind of piece some of that together we
had vowed to slay this
false god yet this promise was no more
than a coerced pledge
when the orders came i felt pride swell
in my chest
despite my longings i knew we were
superior to these
wretched creatures these swine rutted
within crammed filthy temples
none were more misguided than these mad
men
hara seemed to despise religious groups
much like the old prisoner or maybe he
just
despised this group in particular saying
he felt pride when the orders came in
and how these wretched creatures within
their cramped filthy temples are beneath
him
harass also continues to talk about him
being forced to slay this false god
so haros was on a mission to slay a
false god got ambushed by brigands and
then found by a priest who took him into
the labyrinth
horus is frightened as the man who has
taken him starts to talk about him
and his future crime i ignored much of
what he said
until he called my name
smiling he forgave me for the crime i
would soon commit
it was all it's in stone he assured me
horus immediately realized that this man
wasn't seeing any hallucinations or
being burdened by delusions he was
telling the truth
he assumed this man to be a spy and cut
him down immediately
as how is it possible that someone knew
about him and his future before it even
happened
solomon also questioned the same thing
we'll explain it a bit more in his story
but one of his writings talks about a
story of a man with the same name
desires and scars as him
written on a tablet in front of him this
confirms this isn't some one-off
occurrence that this priest guessed on a
whim
he actually knows what's going to happen
almost like it's fate
right after killing the priest haros had
heard squeals everywhere then the
revered delay priest i talked about
had arrived as this rivaling massive
sinew almost as if her body was
separating and forming at the same time
horus had lost his strength and fell to
his knee wanting to look away but at the
same time only wanting to look at her
crawling out of the depths of the earth
was a newborn this newborn was extremely
skinny possessing a more pale brown skin
color
this newborn also didn't look human
either something swam beneath the belly
of the revered though
her flesh was peeling away and pouring
onto the ground like
mud a more slow and thick would be a
good way to describe it
this liquid drowned all the worshippers
nearby everything was indistinguishable
at that moment either birth nor death
could even be made out
horus decided to look for shelter or
safety but his mind was dragging him
closer to the revered as the prayers of
the devout filled his ears
harass could not raise his sword and
kill a mother and child
so he was then left with two options die
by the executioner's axe
or serve the queen haross knew the
correct answer it was an easy one
he became one with the group wearing her
sigil and repeated all the oaths they
followed but in the back of his mind
he knew one day no matter the amount of
praise or honor he had received
one day he would escape horus is a man
consumed with purpose and nobility and
was fated to act this way
as we stated before it was no mere
coincidence that the priest knew the
crime horus would commit
and what his future would hold but no
matter horus was determined to escape
we aren't sure if he was successful in
his escape as we found him dead
but because he's nowhere near a temple
or religious residence and the so-called
sigil of this revered isn't
on his armor it's plausible to assume he
escaped one of the main themes about
this game is the revered beings and
every time we get to meet one we always
fight them immediately and never accept
them
eardrum was a veteran of war so to speak
he's gone through his countless battles
and is exhausted from them
he says no remedy can cure his trembling
hands and anxious
dreams but his brethren spoke of an
immaculate path
that could work airdram was approached
by the ovate the ovate made promises to
eardrim of a way to end the war and
suffering
erdrim trusted the ovate and signed his
name in the deathless doctrine this is a
part of the ritual that involves the
immaculate
see the immaculate resides within the
crypt of the martyr and her followers
guard her as they wait for her arrival
as well as the other followers that gave
themselves up
to be reborn it's a bit complex so i'd
like to summarize their religion and how
it operates i covered this in a lot more
detail in my full lore breakdown of the
game so if you want to see that that'll
be
located at the top but inside the crypt
of the martyr is a religious group
their way of being closer with the
revered god who is the immaculate is to
enshrine themselves
in ice which is said to resonate with
her energy of her eternal winter to be
worthy of enshrining you must be strong
enough to kneel before the immaculate
place your palm upon the deathless
doctrine and surrender your pride your
vanity and your will
as within the religion this is the first
sin once letting go this allows the
immaculate to guide you with her eternal
wisdom
so you may not falter it's been
confirmed that people have seen
visions of her as one man describes it
as a dream of a woman who had an icy
presence who put her hands around his
throat and as he came back
to the present he was still alive but
that icy feeling still remained around
his throat
meaning the two were linked forever the
ovate says that the ritual is necessary
as beyond the ice the old world is
preserved
no war no famine no suffering just
eternal peace
but irjun believes he doesn't deserve
this however yet he still seeks this
power
i do not deserve absolution yet still
i seek it our venerable
order has slaughtered hundreds
and for what so the magistrate
could redraw the borders of our realm
claim victory over an ill-equipped enemy
over children who can barely raise their
swords
eardrum's attitude is now turning as he
finds peace and devotion as now he
doesn't need to agonize over the
problems and burdens of the living as
his ascension and enshrinement await him
we talked about this before but lots of
characters in this game care more about
their future than the present as when
they ascend they'll live forever in
eternal peace so why bother with the
hardships and struggles of the present
when their future will be eternally
peaceful a weight being lifted off their
shoulders in these cases so it makes
them feel more free and
unburdened even though he started
feeling better he was still considered
unworthy of the nectar
but he was determined to prove himself
no matter what later
at some time erdrim met with the ovate
who was prostrated in front of the altar
but out of the corner of his eyes he saw
a shadow move but nothing when
peering over the ovate rose and said the
martyrs are here
the martyrs in this case are highly
revered individuals who didn't give up
their blood or body like others
but their own living memory all sealed
within the ice to preserve the faith in
the immaculate and the doctrine
we then get some other tidbits of audio
when it comes to eardrum about his
distaste for the lesser beings calling
them rats who bow and scrape but are
unworthy and more importantly
how he believes the weak should be
removed and outsiders and those who
disagree with the rest of the group
should not be allowed within the
sanctuary they have built but he's
confident that in time that they will
end up going headfirst into their death
anyway so it shouldn't matter and any of
them who don't do that right away shall
be aided by airdrim himself
and he struggles with this a lot he was
a hardened warrior seeing and winning
many battles yet is constantly rejected
of the nectar
but some of these weaker and less devout
individuals become enshrined and he
feels like that's absurd
later we have a time skip eardrum seems
to be an executioner of sorts
impoverished souls waited for judgment
they would bow and recite the words of
the martyr urjun would take this
opportunity to attack and kill one of
them
once the first fell the others ran into
darkness eardrum held true to his word
sending the weak to their deaths and he
did what he set out to do for in his
mind he was purifying the sanctuary
of the filth that was unneeded morning
after however the wardens had come and
seized him the obey considered him unfit
and impure this is different than
unworthy whereas unworthy was something
he could rewrite in the future assuming
he proved himself there's no coming back
from this
eardrum didn't care as he felt no pain
or burden as he had been cleansed
because of the immaculate's power he was
filled with pride after seeing her
indescribable form
soon after his vision was blurred white
was all he could see
he could feel hands guide him all while
something sharp slipped under his armor
as he stumbled
and fell onto the icy floor claws
digging into the seams between his flesh
and steel
it's unclear whether he died soon after
this or awoke and
died some other way but from what we
have read it's clear that eardrum is a
man of scars he participated in wars
killed hundreds of people and wanted to
stop the trembling effects that the war
has put on his body so he was offered a
solution which as we know is the
doctrine and the immaculate
upon feeling her energy he was relieved
content and
at peace for the first time in a very
long time he wanted to keep this feeling
as the crypt and its followers were
important to him and he deemed others
unworthy as they didn't have any proof
of worthiness in his eyes none of these
people went through his pains and
struggles so why are they even trying to
be enshrined if they aren't even close
to eardrum in his
level of devoution and worthiness so he
took matters into his own hands and
killed those who didn't belong
as punishment he was deemed unfit and
impure and was outcasted and possibly
killed as a result
another small interesting detail is that
with eardrum we get a secret dialogue
when talking to brother corvid he asks
if you can grant him the same thing you
did with his brothers and sisters which
is finding peace
and in more specific peace and death
this goes back to the statement before
about him killing the weak and with this
information maybe he was killing other
groups as well as the crypt of the
martyr in the seat of infinity groups
have very different religious beliefs
but one thing is common amongst the
shells and that is death
as they've all died in some way but
being killed however is a different
story
and that's one that solomon and teal
happened to share he was actually a
pupil
of the seat of infinity in the beginning
but ended up falling in with the
brigands at some point he learned their
teachings and their way of life
mixing droplets of tar with muddy
spirits drinking heavily all the time
and stumbling from one camp to another
teel and his group would steal things
from others most of it being tar
he claimed that these thieves didn't
know the true potential of the tar
and how it was wasted on them when tia
would drink tar he would see a woman in
his vision
tar has an interesting effect on the
human body where it causes
hallucinations but the seed of infinity
uses it constantly
as they think of it as a way of being
closer to the revered going back to the
story teal saw this woman in his visions
he doesn't know her name but we know her
as sister ganesa
where did you find him family
do not answer just come
closer it's a simple pleasure
to glimpse my beloved even
if he's truly gone some part of him
remains with you
ah a small consolation
but i shall accept this mercy
according to theo every movement she
made she created new copies
each joining and splitting apart at the
same time which ended up forming new
copies
the problem with the tar though is that
it was making his flesh peel off his
skin
and the visions of the sester eventually
disappeared
he still reaches for her in the night
but nothing ever happens
he can still hear her voice even in his
head telling him to go back to the
shrine
constantly but he's concerned that they
may not welcome back a lost pupil such
as himself as we stated earlier
deal at this point was becoming
unrecognizable his kin couldn't even
notice who he was and he was outcasted
when talking with baghdad's teal we get
this secret dialogue that solidifies
this
you've got some nerve showing your face
or what's left of it around here
i don't have any time so don't even
think about it
i'm out get on then
he talked to a merchant who offered him
help by sending him to a location that
may cure him the physician told them
that he had two winters to live
after taking into considerations of what
the physician said and what sester
ganessa was telling him to go back to
the seat of infinity
he went back teal when going there hid
his disfigurement beneath his cowl he
was absolutely delirious when entering
the seat of infinity
a sister walked up to him however
welcomed him with open arms and offered
nourishment as he went further into the
shrine he found a fellow pupil
performing a ritual
he slit a knife along his wrist scraping
flesh and bone
the sage accepted this offering tossing
his blood into the fire
thiel described the sacrifice as madness
but also beautiful in some ways
only the revered could cause someone to
do such things to themselves
the oblate then dipped his hand into the
embers drawing back his blackened
fingers from the ash he drew a sigil
beneath teal's eyes
the soot burned his cheek getting hotter
and hotter with every touch
tears stripped from his eyes as the
smoke choked his vision the world itself
felt white and hot
the flames revealed cinders and shadows
but teal wanted more but no matter what
ritual he took part in his flesh was
still decaying it would ultimately lead
to him
and his death at some point in the
future theo was a pupil of the
infinity who then left and ended up
joining the brigands who would steal
from others and drink tar this drinking
of tar
made him see visions of a woman who
would tell him to go back to the shrine
once more
after being outcasted by his kin as he
was unrecognizable and the physician
telling him he had two winters left of
life he would perform rituals like he
used to back when he was a pupil but his
flesh was still peeling
which killed him we then come to our
final shell solomon
solomon was a scholar a person who
thirsts for knowledge as described to us
by his name but
also by brother corvid rather corvid
knew of solomon nothing crazy was
revealed to us about solomon it was more
about brother corvid
and more info about him but solomon's
first audio log says quote
existence is a curious matter the
greatest triumph in the universe gifted
and squandered
i shan't make the same mistake as my
brother when the moment comes i'll
exercise restraint sultan mentions his
brother a lot and that specifically
is the old prisoner no
it can't be
i see it's only his face and his form
stretched across your frame of course
your silence gives it away he always had
too much to say babbling on
and on incessantly
his words wound into such impossible
staggering formations often
contradicting himself
beautifully i do
miss him unfortunately my
dear brother spent too much time beneath
those
infinite golems and this restraint he
talks about
is religion and ascension solomon's
description reads there is no god
because there are no gods solomon is
like the old prisoner they don't believe
in the false truths the other groups
believe in
but where they differ is that the old
prisoner wants to ascend and leave this
plane of existence
solomon is content with his existence he
says that it's a triumph and that's true
being born is something we think of is
simple but it's also a very
unpredictable matter
and says that the people of this world
receive the gift of life but wasted on
them focusing on their future life
where others within the game focus on
the future which is the afterlife
solomon likes to focus on the present
day life a lot more
a lot of solomon's dialogue has to do
with the old prisoner as well
solomon and the old prisoner used to be
with the brothers and sisters of the
order as we know from brother corvin
solomon also watched in horror as his
brother drank the nectar
this is a call from after you beat the
twice born where cester ganesa talks
about a heretic who drank too much of
the nectar
and turned into a different being not
even human this is the old prisoner and
a story about him
solomon watched this drinking of the
nectar event occur and was horrified
more audio uncovers more of the
relationship between the two
the two are both on the same page with
religious groups and false truths but as
we uncovered
one went too far where the others stayed
content but says that the knowledge that
they've learned is only afforded by the
silence of
others as everyone is strict in their
beliefs and refuses to listen to others
and who don't agree with them
solomon believes in fate and that it's
not ours to defy but
to fulfill and as we know the old
prisoner doesn't believe in this which
is why he took the glance for himself in
an attempt to ascend
solomon says that everyone is chosen and
even naming us
the unborn solomon knew of our arrival
and knew it would happen as if it was
fate
solomon seemed to not understand fate
though in the beginning of his life
as one day when he was within the
stacked archives inside this archive is
faces of the infinity that are etched
into the stone
stacked in columns weight of this
knowledge could kill a man if he were to
grab one of these tablets in haste as
the rest would fall over and crush him
within the archives there was a tablet
and this had the same name as solomon
the same desires the solomon and the
same scars as him
but he never wrote it so how was that
possible
saying can it even be called history if
it's being written by someone who can
see into the future
just as someone can see into the past
the people he's referring to
are sears people who are supernatural
with insight and can see into the future
solomon claims this stuff to be
unsatisfactory that these seers wield
weapons in things they can't even
understand
they uphold laws that they ignore and
that they've unearthed a tablet
unseen before and he's very confused by
all of this
and solomon was possibly warned about
this by his brother
and then this is where solomon comes to
an end as he talks about an assylian
solomon like many would do read far into
his fate and found out that someone is
going to kill him in the near future
well he doesn't blame them as he
understands it as fate saying that he
cannot hold on to this body when another
needs it far more
possibly referencing us when we awake
his body in the future
and that's solomon's ending a scholar
who seek knowledge who discovered the
true intentions of fate
knowing that you can only fulfill and
not defy so he was content with his
present life
not worrying about the future and ended
up reading and finding about his death
but
understands that that's how life goes
and that
is the lore of all the shells in mortal
shell and i must say
this was complicated these audio logs we
see are only glimpses as we stated
before
not full stories and not a cohesive
timeline but i think i nailed down the
story and timeline the best i could so
feel free to give your interpretations
in the comments below as i'd love to
hear them
but with that thank you for joining me
on this journey of the lore of all the
shells in mortal shell
and take care everyone i'll see you in
another future video
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
hmm you